I ask you a hypothetical question oh
dear I don't like hypothetical question
so I don't think you're gonna like the
real one either do you have the papers
not yet but I'm so curious why is it
taking so long for you guys to be nice
okay because I can't sing if I could I
would have been in Mamma Mia I could not
I dare not put myself my check and
you're both armed and scenes with Tom
Hanks often assuming that you learn from
him as an actor that you can use in your
own craft yes is that easy well he told
us that only said that I said was like a
pep talk or it's PG be what he is you it
makes you good I mean his confidence
meant a lot his ability to try things
and change them up believe it or not I
don't get actors to say yes all the time
I'm turned down like all of us are loud
and and this was one of the rare
occasions where every actor I went to
all my first choices said yes
so why do you folks need to go see the
post in theaters I think because of who
Steve in an attic see it's very his
cinematic skill is he's the consummate
filmmaker and I think he animates even
the most what could be really static
moments in a beautiful way but aside
from that it's also very it's very
romantic and it's very optimistic and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
making art that does that for us right
now I love the idea of sitting extra
person that I do not know and
everybody's having their own experience
and yet it's all happening together and
we have found in showing the post that
there is a communal spontaneous reaction
that happens in multiple places
throughout the duty where it's
infectious and people applaud and they
laugh and they feel each other having
these kind of little epiphanies the time
says 7,000 pages detailing how the White
House has been lying about the Vietnam
War for 30 years the way they lied those
days have to be over
you